let's take a quick look on how to create
and use service accounts service
accounts are used when you want to
authenticate machines like compute
engine VMs to use other Google cloud
services to create a service account go
to the permissions page go to the
service accounts tab and click create
service account give you a new service
account a name and make sure you furnish
a new private key keep this key safe
because you cannot download it again
let's go to the permissions tab to lock
down this service account search for
your service account and then click
roles I only want this service account
to create disks and snapshots so I'm
going to remove the editor role and add
the compute storage admin role instead
in my compute engine instance I've
already copied the private key over in
this example I'm going to use g-cloud to
create a snapshot use the service
account email and the key file with the
activate service account command now use
g-cloud init to configure g-cloud to use
our new service account this service
account only has a compute storage admin
scope if we try to create a new instance
it'll fail but if we try to create a new
disk it'll work fine